now that we know the magnitude of the
acceleration due to gravity at 400
kilometers above the surface of the
earth where the space station might hang
out what i want to do in this video is
think about how fast does the space
station need to be moving in order to
keep missing the earth as it's falling
or another way to think about it in
order to stay in orbit in order to
maintain its circular motion around the
earth so you we know from our studies of
circular motion so far what's keeping it
going in circular motion assuming that
it has a constant speed is some type of
centripetal acceleration and that
centripetal acceleration is acceleration
due to gravity and we figured out what
it was at 400 kilometers and so we know
that that centripetal acceleration let
me write it here in pink we know that
that the magnitude of that centripetal
acceleration has to be equal to the
speed or the magnitude of the velocity
squared divided by divided by
r would r is the radius of the circular
path so in this case would be the radius
of the orbit which would be the radius
of the earth plus the altitude so that
we already figured out in the last video
is 6771
kilometers and we could actually let's
just solve this for v and then we can
put in the numbers in our calculator so
you multiply both sides by r and you
flip the two sides you get v squared is
equal to the magnitude of our
acceleration times the radius the
magnitude of our velocity or our speed
is equal to the square root of our
acceleration times or the magnitude of
our acceleration times the radius and so
let's get our calculator out and you can
verify that the units work out this is
meters per second squared times meters
which gives us meters squared per second
squared take the square root of that you
get meters per second which is the
appropriate units but let's get our
calculator out and actually calculate
this
let me see my calculator sitting on my
other screen
and there you go
and then
we want to calculate
the principal square root of
the acceleration due to gravity at this
altitude the magnitude of the
acceleration due to gravity that
altitude is 8.69
8.69 meters per second squared times the
radius of our circular path it's going
to be the radius of earth which is 6 371
kilometers plus the 400 kilometers of
altitude that we have in this scenario
so that gives us six point we did this
in the last video 6.771
times 10 to the sixth meters and it's
important that everything here is in
meters our acceleration is in meters per
second squared this right over here is
in meters so the units don't do anything
strange
and then we get a drum roll for how fast
and this is going to be in meters per
second we already thought about how the
units will work out
we get 7670
i could say 71 but actually i'm just
going to stick to three significant
digits 7670
meters per second so let me write that
down the necessary velocity to stay in
orbit is
7670
meters per second so let's just
conceptualize that for a second every
second it's going over 7 000 meters or
every second it's going over seven
kilometers every second it's going to
get the super if we assume that's the
direction it's traveling and it's going
at the super super fast speed and if we
want to translate that into kilometers
per hour
you just take
7670
meters per second if you want to know
how many meters it's going to do in an
hour you just say well there's 3 600
there's 3 600 seconds per hour
and so if you multiply that that's how
far how many meters it will travel in an
hour but if you want that in kilometers
you just divide by a thousand you have
one kilometer for every 1000
meters meters will cancel out seconds
will cancel out and you are left with
kilometers per hour so let's do that so
we get so that was our previous answer
we multiply by 3600
multiply by 3600 and then divide by a
thousand so we really could have just
multiplied by three point six
and then we get
twenty seven thousand roughly twenty
seven thousand six hundred kilometers
per hour so this is really an
unfathomable
speed and you might be wondering how
does such a big thing maintain that type
of speed because you know we you know
even a jet plane which is nowhere near
this fast has to have these huge engines
to maintain its its its speed how does
this thing maintain it and the
difference between this and a jet plane
is that a jet or a car or any or if i
throw a ball or anything like that but a
jet plane let's take let's focus on a
jet plane so we don't have to worry
about other things a jet plane has to
travel through the air
it has to travel through the air and
actually it uses the air as kind of its
form of propulsion it sucks in the air
and then it spits out the air really
fast but it has all of this air
resistance so if the engines were to
just shut shut down all the air all the
air would provide all would bump into
the plane and provide essentially
friction to slow down the plane what the
space station or the space shuttle or
something in space has going for itself
is that it's traveling in an almost
complete vacuum not 100 complete vacuum
but almost complete vacuum so it has
pretty much no air resistance very you
know negligible air resistance to have
to deal with so we know from newton's
laws an object in motion tends to stay
in motion so once this thing gets going
it doesn't have air to slow it down
it'll keep staying in that it'll keep
staying that speed in fact if it did not
have gravity if it did not have gravity
which is creating this
causing the centripetal acceleration
right over here it would just go in a
straight path it would go in a straight
path forever and ever and that brings up
an interesting point because if you are
in orbit like this traveling at this
very very very fast speed you have to
make sure that you don't vary from the
speed too much if you slow down if you
slow down you will slowly spiral into
the earth and if you speed up a lot
beyond that speed you will slowly spiral
away from the earth you'll slowly spiral
away from the earth because then the
centripetal acceleration due to gravity
won't be enough to keep you in a perfect
circular path so you really have to stay
pretty close to that speed right there